wanted to get this gent on because man i
love his reporting and his reporting
about what went down
in the uh meeting room wednesday night
when the
nba players all got together to discuss
what the cancellation of playoff games
that was brought on by the milwaukee
bucks decision to do it
um what it was going to mean and how to
put it all back together
and the end if they wanted to in order
to play
and the nba and the nba players
association in just the last 15 minutes
sent out a joint statement saying that
they will play
starting saturday chris haynes of yahoo
his material is must read especially his
latest back here on the rich eisen show
how are you chris
i'm exhausted man i'm exhausted man
it's been a whirlwind i bet how long
have you been in the bubble chris
i've been here since june 29th i wanted
to um to get here early
before everybody so you were one of the
first
in is what you're saying
yeah i got here a week so that's a week
before the players arrive
um i came as part of um
it's part of turner um just so they
could have um they allow
the league allow you know espn to have a
reporter on the ground earlier
and turner the two broadcast partners so
i came here early for turner well and we
just saw broadcast partners are going to
be part of
um moving forward in terms of what the
players
told the nba i imagine would be required
to at least have them entertain
uh a return and begin to
entertain people who on wednesday they
thought to themselves we don't want to
do it
and so let's walk through all of this
um with your report and um
for those who um are maybe a little bit
fresh to this this was wednesday night
after the bucks decided to not play
and the thing that kind of left me left
at me uh from your from your article is
this was not a unified decision to stop
playing
in the nba from the players right
no it wasn't at all this was uh you know
i know boycott is being used but
really it wasn't that you know a boycott
is a
organized plan of attack uh where
everybody is in sync
that wasn't the case the the milwaukee
bucks actually
intended to forfeit that game and
and take a loss and then the series
would have been 3-2
in their favor that was their way that
was their action but they did that
without performing the
orlando magic and without informing
anybody else
for that matter and so then that left
that left the rest of the slated games
uh that left players on those other
teams to like damn
there's no way we can go out there and
play now like like what are we doing and
so you know there was a lot of
frustration and motion and tension man
you know already
already built up just from what's going
on in society and the latest shooting in
wisconsin
and then everybody's blindsided by what
just happened with the bucks
and lebron james was one of the ones you
know he was really frustrated but
his reasoning for that was because it's
like
we didn't plan to do this this wasn't an
organized effort
so what are we doing like if we're going
to boycott we have to be
asking for something in return we have
to demands have to be met
in order for us to go back to play what
do we do we just go back and play
i mean what does boycott one game do and
then we come back and play like what
what is that setting so that was
his frustration that it wasn't thought
through and now everybody is lumped into
this
trying to figure out how they get
themselves out and you know there's a
lot of different personalities in the
world a lot of different players and at
first lebron james
in the lakers they they they voted no we
didn't want to play and they they left
over he left the room clippers followed
him
and uh leading up to tomorrow i mean
leading up to the next day which was
thursday
uh they finally got the clippers in the
lakers on board and
it took a lot like you have to command
chris paul andre gonzalez
got his hat from cj mccollum like they
work around the clock
hours get very little sleep over that
last 48-hour period
and try to just try to get as many
people on on the same page as possible
and
so i have to commend them for um you
know bringing nba basketball back
let's focus on the la teams for a second
here chris uh chris haynes on the rich
eisen show
so um let's start obviously with lebron
how did it go from lebron uh
understanding
the bucks move but a little bit chafed
over the fact that it wasn't thought
through with everybody
and with a proper end game to
leaving the meeting to agreeing
after all to come back walk me through
all how does that all
square yeah well this uh
you know lebron since since the nba
you know ever since the nba suspended
play march 11th you know due to
coronavirus
outbreak in the league lebron has been
adamant that
it's in everyone's best interest if we
get this season
underway you know if safety protocols
and
what things permit um and so
during that meeting you know like i said
if you have to remember that meeting
was an hour you know a couple hours
from everybody uh counseling the games
and so there's still a state of shock
from everybody
there's frustration there's tension like
everything is built up in that room
and so then when you're hearing all you
know when you're hearing players give
reasons
of why people should leave um this
bubble
um you know it it was just a frustrating
period
and i i think you know and i think at a
certain point lebron was just
you know he he got kind of fed up in
that moment
and you know udonis haslam um he was the
one that asked lebron like what do you
want to do
it's on you you to face a lead you know
it goes as you go
what you gonna do yeah lebron
you know he was like we're out and you
know they
they walked out and the only um the rest
of his teammates followed him
um the only only elector that stayed was
dwight howard which
and the clippers did as well well it's
jumped out at me howard because howard
was one
who one of the guys who instagrammed out
before
the bubble when kyrie irving was saying
there shouldn't be a bubble or at least
through
through that one out there howard was
one of the guys who basically said i
agree
so he's the guy who actually stayed
behind after the lakers walked out
that one just kind of jumped out at me
and
i i'm just again wondering how it went
from
you know uh anger boiling over or at
least
wanting to just take a beat to
to getting lebron and the clippers
unified
do you know any more about that yeah
well they're they were up all night
you know players on both sides up all
night talking you know there was you
know
small meetings you know marginal size
meetings um you know just guys just
trying to organize and
try to just figure out what's the best
path moving forward
and not only that just trying to figure
out like what demands are we going to
ask for right now
you know because we're in this hiatus
mini hiatus period
but what it boiled down to was
i think rich everybody was just heated
like there was so much going on that day
everybody needed a good night's sleep
you know just to
rest and you know come back with a clear
mind
and um the next day you know members of
the executive committee
reached out to braun and luke williams's
clippers and asked how they they're in
or out
well i said they were in and the funny
thing about it was you kind of you know
the lakers for the meeting the next
morning they came 45 minutes late
to the meeting and so they they held the
meeting up the meeting was supposed to
happen at 11 a.m
it didn't start to around 11 45 and so
uh
i don't know what was going on there i
don't know what led to that but
after lebron so after that 11 a.m
meeting there was a meeting in the
afternoon with the owners players and
owners and
lebron was really forceful and stunned
and what he was asking for the owners
you know you know tell them they need to
do more and do more to use their
resources to
you know affect change within the black
community um
to to help you know alter laws and you
know so he went in and
and the owners they said that
the owner said that you know they will
they will do more
and so he left that owner that that
meeting
feeling like it was comfortable to play
and he certainly felt good so that's
those were kind of all
the elements that led to lebron
ultimately um changing his mind
chris haynes of yahoo sports here a few
minutes left uh here on the rich eisen
show i know you've got
um a lot of players finally being uh
accessible after the last couple days i
know you've got a lot
going on so i appreciate the time uh
zubots i'm sure you've heard of the
clippers uh flat out disputed
uh one of the i guess more juicy nuggets
in your report uh by giving pulling back
the curtain on
a lot of that tension that you mentioned
on wednesday night uh patrick beverly
um you know snapping at michelle roberts
uh of the players association that he
pays
her salary and uh he can interrupt her
whenever i guess he felt like it
what's your response to that
well i i stand by my reporting of what's
in my story
um yeah there was a heated moment
that happened at that point where
michelle roberts was trying to explain
um the financial ramifications if
everybody was to leave and there was a
portion of what she was saying that
uh pat didn't agree with and um
he kept trying to interrupt her
[Music]
and then uh that that's when um
that's when he said something along the
lines of
you know no she asked no that's how it
is she asked how
um how do you want no no okay will you
allow me to speak you know to finish my
point
there he said something online said no
you know
i pay your salary we pay your salary
something along those lines so
i spent my reporting on that and uh
you know i think you know he i did find
out that
he went and spoke to her the next day
um and taylor brooks reported that as
well
for return for bleach report that he
spoke to the next day and
apologized they're they're they're
supposed to be in good standing as of
right now but yeah
that was a point um during a during the
meeting that where
things got a little heated and chris
paul had to stand up and say something
as well as udonis hassle okay last one
for you chris
especially perfect to answer this since
your information is
is airtight and buttoned up and you know
everything or you're trying to get to
know everything and you beat as you
mentioned
the players to the bubble by a week can
you
um give a little bit more um
i i i guess background on how the bubble
might be affecting everybody i mean
chris paul
i mean paul george saying that he was
depressed anxious
um that you know um sitting there
hermetically sealed up in an amusement
park and resort
for as long as the players have while
the rest of the
the country seems to be burning i mean
literally in the state of california
but we're talking about the streets of
wisconsin uh what what's
happening in our world how that void
is affecting the players mentally and
might have led to a lot of what we're
talking about
right now yeah i mean just players you
know
look it's you know it has obstacles when
you when you're here and
you're not around family and you know
you can't
do anything or go anywhere you know so
you know that that has is issues um and
then you add you know just the latest
shooting
of what i said and you have to remember
like players they wanted to come over
here because
they they wanted to keep the message
alive um
they wanted to keep the message on
social justice um
and i think when that latest shooting
happened there was a sense of
helplessness
sense of that you know they're powerless
and you know i cleared to just being you
know cry for help
um because they realize that
you know even though black lives matter
is painted across the court and
everybody on campus is wearing black
lives matter sugar
is that to a large extent
even through all these movements and
kneeling during the national anthem
that black lives matter still isn't
mattering
in certain places and so there was hurt
you know the guys are dealing with
anxiety issues depression
issues and feeling guilt there's a lot
of guilt because they feel like
you know we're here and we're
distracting the world
because this is what it is rich i'm
sorry to be long-winded no please
but just for context before the bubble
was started
you remember there were protests going
on all across the country and this is
the first time in my lifetime where i
see
massive protesters featuring all walks
of life
all different shades of colors and that
was beautiful and
you started you started to see
cops being held accountable uh from
for unlawful shootings that was rare
we rarely do we see that and so that was
progress that was being made and that
was why
some players are hesitant to come over
because they felt like
it's going to take it's going to take
all the focus away from
what has been a good movement right now
and i think with the latest one in
milwaukee man
i just i think every everything just hit
ahead and
you know players you know players who
are dealing with just being isolated
here
in the first place and you add that on
top of it you know it was just
i think that's that's all the things
that led up to what happened on that
historic day which was wednesday
thanks chris appreciate you um giving us
that information in the background i
knew
i knew you'd uh you'd be able to to
provide it and i appreciate the time
are you there for the duration uh is you
there until they hand out the larry ob
yes sir that that is the plan wow okay
so look look for my call look for my
call we'll be calling you again chris
and i'm
i'm uh i'm i'm glad to hear your voice
and i'm glad you're doing
you're well and uh and we'll chat soon
all right wrist take care my guy right
back at you that's chris haynes
must follow must read again go read that
i mean it's just
every word was i was hanging on every
single word
of his article which is again entitled
inside the emotional
48 hours that saved the nba's
bubble